how would you respect your children's
beliefs instead of imposing your own in
some ways I probably did a better job
with Julian in relationship to that than
you does he argue more with you maybe
he's just more wrong than me I think
that's what's going on
well I think in some ways that was true
when he was a little kid because he
broke a lot more rules than you did you
broke more when you were a teenager or
at least you let us know more about the
rules how to be honest yeah he told me
tell the truth no matter what and so I
told the truth no matter what and then
he'd be like why did you tell me that I
was like why I didn't I didn't mean tell
me every single thing you do